all right
fetty jose on twitter wants to know
does ryan fitzpatrick win with the
cowboys roster should the cowboys trade
for him shireen
your thoughts
yeah they'd be much better off i think
but i'm ready for the cowboys to tank
for tua i mean i mean tank for two
tank for trevor two of us last year to
tank for trevor that's what i want to
see i want to see them in that position
to have to make a decision do we go with
dak prescott or we do we go for trevor
lawrence but i don't think they're gonna
get the first pick i do think they have
a top five pick they've moved up there
now after the loss uh last night but
yeah i think ryan fitzpatrick would win
some games for him but at this point
mike what are you playing for in in 2020
i mean they're not going to win a super
bowl right so get the draft pick
yeah look hey i'm a firm believer in
that that you know and it's the great
disconnect in the nfl we we talk all the
time about how everyone wants to win
every single game possible and then when
we see the final draft order we realize
how valuable it is to be higher on the
list and what teams will give up just to
move a few spots so yes once you know
it's over once you know it's done
there's no benefit in winning evaluate
your young players put your backups out
there see what the future holds by way
of the guys who otherwise aren't good
enough to play and then nature will take
its course and you will lose enough
games and maybe you're in position to
get trevor lawrence and dallas which
would create
quite
quite quite a situation in dallas if
they're in position to get trevor
lawrence and they have to decide what to
do with dak prescott but look i agree
with you fitzpatrick is better than ben
denucci he's better than andy dalton
frankly and i put the poll question up
last monday when it was obvious andy
dalton wouldn't be able to play last
week who helps the cowboys win sunday
night ben dinucci garrett gilbert or
colin kaepernick and 47 000 votes came
in and 60 said kaepernick now it wasn't
going to happen
because of the covet protocols you're
not going to be cleared
to to play by sunday and even if you are
you're not going to practice by then but
uh
look
you get what you deserve when you trot
out ben dinucci and garrett gilbert as
your top two quarterbacks and maybe
they're already implementing the tanking
strategy maybe the joke's on everyone
else because maybe the cowboys are
winning by losing all right one more
quick one a red zone out is it time to
accept that carson wentz
is what he is talented but inconsistent
something's happened to him mike i just
i don't know what it is but 14
interceptions is the most he's ever
thrown in a season that was his rookie
he has 12 this season along with 12
touchdowns he's lost four fumbles he's
not the same guy and to say ben and ucci
outplayed him last night i wouldn't go
that far
but it wasn't far off i mean there
wasn't a big gap there he's just not
playing very well for whatever reason
and they have a big rehab project or
they're gonna have to move on from him
he strikes me as a guy who is trying too
hard to validate the decisions that have
been made by the eagles in him trading
up in 2016 to get him in the second spot
of the draft picking him over nick foles
after folz became a super bowl mvp and
almost got the eagles back to the nfc
championship game the following year and
that's when the eagles said sea and nick
were sticking with carson wentz and then
they give carson wentz the huge contract
i feel like he believes he can reverse
everyone's perception of him with one
throw and he's constantly trying to make
that one throw and he's trying too hard
and he's going it's it's almost like the
jameis winston trying to do more than
you're physically capable of doing and
it leads to outcomes that make people
say
why is that guy
on the football field and if he keeps it
up he's not going to be on the football
field much longer for the philadelphia
eagles
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports